9 preeminentes activistas y políticos de
la oposición han sido condenados hoy por
la justicia hongkonesa a penas que
oscilan entre los 8 y los 18 meses de
cárcel entre los condenados figura jimmy
lai un célebre magnate de la prensa y
propietario del apple daily un diario
muy crítico con los gobiernos de pekín y
hong kong la haya recibido una sentencia
de 12 meses pero su horizonte legal es
mucho más sombrío porque le esperan dos
procesos por violar la nueva ley de
seguridad nacional con penas que
alcanzan la cadena perpetua león con
hawk alias pelo largo y una de las
figuras más iconoclastas de la escena
política hong kong esa ha recibido la
pena más larga de 18 meses el tribunal
ha sido más generoso con el octogenario
martín lee el padre de la democracia en
hong kong que debido a su edad y a su
largo historial de servicios públicos
prestados no pisará la cárcel porque su
condena lleva aparejada una suspensión
de dos años los hechos sentenciados esta
mañana se remontan a agosto de 2019
cuando las protestas eran cotidianas en
la excolonia la policía había permitido
la concentración en él
parque victoria pero no la manifestación
posterior que fue encabezada por los
acusados éstos habían alegado durante el
juicio que sencillamente organizaron la
evacuación del parque pero la magistrada
ha sentenciado que en realidad quisieron
burlar la prohibición legal